ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING ON MAY NINTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING CALLS. ITEMS
EXCUSE ME.
CALLING FOR MEMBERS THIS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FIRST WELCOME TO OUR GOVERNMENT
HEARING JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS BEFORE WE START.
FIRST OF ALL I DO WANT TO TAKE
THIS HALF A SECOND IN A TO
SIGNAL AUDREY HAVE.
A YOUNG MAN THAT IS.
SHADOWING ME TODAY'S WITH
FOSTER CARE AND HIS NAME'S CHRIS
CURRENT FERNANDES CONCERT HE'S
HERE OF WITH US TODAY THANK YOU
FOR COMING TODAY.
MISTER SPEAKER HAS APPOINTED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN TO FILL
THE DEMOCRATIC VACANCY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
WE A FOURTEEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY PLEASE NOTE THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL ITEM NUMBER THREE
A. B. TWO THOUSAND THREE DALY
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE HERE
HEARING.
WE HAVE SIX ITEMS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT ITEM ONE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR LIMON.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT GLORIA.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND ITEMS THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN S. B. FOURTEEN NINETY
SIX S. B. FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN
AND FOURTEEN NINETY NINE. ALL BY
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
IN ORDER TO MOVE ALONG IN THE
AGENDA. MANNER HOA PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ALLOW TWO MINUTES IN
SUPPORT AND WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION. BEYOND THESE
LIMITS PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION POSITION.
WE APPRECIATE BREVITY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BILLS ARE
HEARD IN SIGN IN ORDER OUR FIRST
BILL TODAY.
WELL I STARTED TO HAVE A.
WE DID.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND.
.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
ADWARE CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE WALDRON WALDRON HERE BLOOM
CABALLERO COOLEY. COOLEY HERE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON HERE LACKEY
MALL AND VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LIKED
SOMEONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WALDRON.
SO.
GOVERNOR POTIONS THE SECOND
EVERYBODY'S EXCITED TODAY.
YEAH WE GOT A.
ALRIGHT PRO FIRST UP TODAY'S
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHT.
STRIP CULTURAL SORRY RUN A RUSH
TODAY SIGH.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM
CABALLERO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY MULLIN PHOTO.
VOEPEL OUT.
I EXCUSE ME.
OKAY CAN THINK CALENDARS UP
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON AND START
ARE. LOVELY AFTERNOON WITH ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
THRILLED TO BE HERE WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO. ARE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA'S
SUSTAINABLE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACT
WHICH WOULD INCENTIVIZE THE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
WORKFORCE AND LOW INCOME
HOUSING.
ALONG TRANSIT PRIORITY QUARTERS.
THIS BILL A WITH A HOW AIMS TO
TRY MAKE A DENT IN THE ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION HOMES OUR STATE
NEEDS OVER THE NEXT SIX YEARS BY
CREATING A NEW STATEWIDE OPT IN
PROGRAM. IT AMENDS DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS TWO ALLOWS FOR THE USE
OF FLOOR AREA RATIO BASE
CALCULATION SYSTEM RATHER THAN
THE DWELLING UNITS PER ACRE AND
MANY OF YOU PUBLIC CAME VERY
FAMILIAR WITH DURING YOUR TOURS
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT SERVICE.
THIS WILL ESSENTIALLY ALLOW FOR
MORE SMALLER UNITS TO BE BUILT
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE UNDER
CURRENT RULES.
TWENTY PERCENT OF THESE UNITS
UNDER THIS BILL WOULD BAR
PROPOSED TO BE AT OR BELOW FIFTY
PERCENT AREA MEDIAN INCOME AND
REMAIN AT THAT AFFORDABILITY
LEVEL FOR FIFTY FIVE YEARS.
ADDITIONALLY IMPACT FEES WILL BE
CALCULATED BASED ON SQUARE FEET
RATHER THAN A PER UNIT BASIS AND
HIDE THE PROJECT WOULD REMAIN
WOULD STILL BE REGULATED BY THE
UNDERLYING BASE ZONING. SO ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT MUCH TALLER
BUILDINGS WHICH HAVE BEEN ACTING
IN THE BUILDING RECENTLY THIS IS
NOT THAT.
BIGGEST GRAYSON A THE CASA ACT
DOES NOT USE PUBLICLY FUNDED
DOLLARS IN THIS IS IMPORTANT
WHEN I TALK ABOUT SUBSIDIZING
THESE UNITS WITH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS FOR USING MARKET DRIVEN
APPROACHES. TO CREATE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS.
THIS BILL.
IS A LABOR OF LOVE FOR OUR THAT
WAS JOINT EFFORT THAT WAS A
BURKE OUT OF A CONVERSATION I
HAD WITH SOME OF MY I'VE OF
FORMER COLLEAGUES IN CITY OF SAN
DIEGO SPECIFICALLY.
COUNCILMEMBER GEORGETTE GOMEZ
AYE ENACTED IT WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE THE REPRESENTATIVE OF FOR
THE BILL SPONSORED THE CITY SAN
DIEGO MORE THE TOP.
ALONG WITH LARA GATES WHO IS A
POLICY ADVISER FOR KATZENBERG
ALGUMAS.
MR. WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA EVAN FAULKNER OF SAN
DIEGO AS WELL AS THE ENTIRE CITY
COUNCIL. AYE WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THE MEASURE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LIKE EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA WERE STRUGGLING TO.
TO BUILD ENOUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THE RESIDENTS.
AS MR GLORIA MENTIONED ON THE
BILL CAME TO US FROM A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER WHO'S KIND OF ON
THE FRONT LINES OF TRYING TO.
TO DEVELOP AND.
AND PROVIDE THAT KIND OF.
RESIDENTIAL ASSISTANCE.
THIS BILL IS AN OPT IN FOR
CITIES OF FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
WISH TO ADOPT THIS ORDINANCE.
I MISS ALSO ARE NOT TO INFER
DEVELOPER SO WE THINK IT'S A
PERFECT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP ON BETWEEN CITIES
AND DEVELOPERS WHO WISH TO. OF
FIND THE RIGHT PLACE AND THE
RIGHT TIME FOR THIS TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT.
COOL AND.
WE DO THINK THAT.
.
THAT THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT I KNOW THAT YOUR
ANALYSIS DID RAISE THE QUESTION
OF.
WHETHER IT'S NEEDED AND WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN SAN DIEGO.
WHILE YES THERE ARE SOME OF
THESE PROPOSALS THAT COULD PUT
BE PUT FORTH.
BY COMMUNITIES ON THEIR OWN
THIS BY HAVING A STATE STATUTE
AYE WE CAN WE CAN.
TRUNCATE A LOT OF THE PROCESS
WE CAN REALLY MOVE MUCH MORE
QUICKLY AND TO GET THESE
RESIDENTIAL UNITS ON THE STREET
VERY VERY QUICKLY.
AND AND HAVING THAT STATE
STATUTE GIVES US FOR THE ADDED
OOMPH IN ORDER FOR THE CITIES TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR
ORDINANCES SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AGAIN WE DO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE HERE WHO CAN
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE BUT WE DO ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BUT THANK YOU DEBORAH CARL'S
WITH A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AARON GROWTH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN WHITE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA HOUSING ALLIANCE
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
SING NOT AND WE HAVE A MOTION
ALREADY. AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
SUSPECT AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I REALLY LIKE IT OPT
PART SO WHO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
A ROLL CALL FOR IT BECAUSE.
I CAN THINK TODAY SORRY
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM
CABALLERO COME BIRO AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY MULLIN
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BACKGROUND CHECKS ECLIPSE.
NEXT UP ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE.
WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA HAS
THE SEWERS A SEWER SYSTEM THAT
VARIES CONSIDERABLY.
IN SIZE AND QUALITY CONVEYING
I'M SU WHICH CAN BE EXPRESSLY
DIFFICULT FOR SMALL SEWER
SYSTEMS BECAUSE THEY OFTEN HAVE
FEWER RESOURCES FOR MAINTENANCE
AND TREATMENT CONSOLIDATING.
SMALL SEWER SYSTEMS CAN HELP
ADDRESS AS SUCH CHALLENGES
HOWEVER. CURRENT CURRENTLY THERE
IS A KEY BARRIER TO CITIES THAT
WANT TO CONSOLIDATE EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS OF VOTE OF
THE CITY AND ITS RESIDENTS TO
SELL SEWER SYSTEMS.
SINCE THE COSTS. OF THESE
ELECTIONS IT'S PROHIBITIVE FOR A
MANY SMALL CITIES I'M HAVING
SUCH A HIGH BORDER THRESHOLD IS
PROBLEMATIC MORE OVER THE SALE
OF THE DRINKING WATERS. A WATER
SYSTEMS ONLY REQUIRE A MAJORITY
OF VOTE FROM CITIES AND ITS
RESIDENTS OF THIS BILL WOULD
THEREFORE ALLOW A CITY TO
CONSOLIDATE ITS SEWER SYSTEM
WITH A MAJORITY VOTE.
UP OF ITS COUNCIL AND LOCAL
RESIDENTS. THIS THANK YOU.
THIS WILL ENCOURAGE
CONSOLIDATION AND ULTIMATELY
IMPROVE OUR STATE SEWER OP
INFRASTRUCTURE TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE HAVE.
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENTING
LIBERTY.
UTILITIES AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA A WATER SO STATES WHO
ARE SELF INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU.
I MY NAME IS CHRIS SALARIO I AM
PRESIDENT THANKS YOU HAVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF FINANCE FOR LIBERTY
UTILITIES AND I'M HERE TODAY.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ONE SEVEN NINE.
I LIBERTY UTILITIES PROVIDES
DRINKING WATER SERVICES TO A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
BECAUSE OF ANNUAL OPERATING
DEFICITS.
THE CITY OF PARIS MADE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO SELL IT
SMALL WATER AND SEWER UTILITIES
AND MY COMPANY WAS SELECTED.
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE PROCESS
THE SALE OF THE UTILITIES
REQUIRED A PUBLIC VOTE OF THE
CITY RESIDENTS.
THE CITY COUNCIL PLACE MEASURE
G. NH ON THE NOVEMBER STE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BALLOT.
MEASURE G. AUTHORIZED THE SALE
OF SEWER UTILITY AND REQUIRED TO
SUPERMAJORITY OR TWO THIRDS OF
THE VOTERS.
MEASURE H. AUTHORIZED THE SALE
OF THE TWO WATER UTILITIES AND
REQUIRED A SIMPLE MAJORITY OF
VOTES.
MEASURE H. PASSED WITH SIXTY
FOUR PERCENT OF THE VOTERS
SUPPORTING THE SALE THE WATER
UTILITIES. MEASURE MEASURE G.
FAILED WITH SIXTY TWO PERCENT OF
THE VOTERS SUPPORTING THE SALE
OF THE. SEWER UTILITY.
AB TWO ONE SEVEN NINE ENCOURAGES
VOLUNTARY CONSOLIDATION A
MUNICIPAL SEWER UTILITIES BY
ALLOWING THE VOTERS TO APPROVE
THE SALE OF THE SEWER UTILITY BY
A SIMPLE MAJORITY VOTE. SIMILAR
TO THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT FOR
THE SALE OF WATER UTILITIES
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER COMPUTER LOW ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION.
IS THE STATE WIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF THAT PUBLIC WATER
SUPPLIERS THAT ARE REGULATED BY
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
WE ALSO HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE.
WE FEEL THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF FOCUSING
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ON
WORKING ON CONSOLIDATION FOR
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS. WE FEEL
LIKE THOSE SAME ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT YOU CAN GET FROM
CONSOLIDATING DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS YOU CAN ALSO GET FROM
CONSOLIDATING WASTE WATER OR
SEWER SYSTEMS AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE SPELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WAS WE HAVE A.
THREE IF WE HAVE A MOTION WE
NEED A SECOND.
AND WE ARE MOTION A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVE A ERA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WHEN YOU HEAR. TWO
DIFFERENT VOTING.
THRESHOLDS.
THE PUBLIC IS SO FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THIS IS REALLY NICE TO HAVE IT
ALL. CONTINUITY SO I WILL
BUSINESS OR IN YOUR BUILDING
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS ACT WHERE
CURRY. ADWARE CURRY I WALDRON
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I COVER EURO COMPARE AYE
COOLEY. YOU COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY MULLIN
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE YOU.
MEASURES OF SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR THAT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN A. B. THIRTY ONE NINETY
FOUR DID DALY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR DALY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
WAS IT WAS APPROVED.
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
TO LIMIT THE LOCAL AGENCIES
ABILITY TO DISAPPROVE OR REQUIRE
DENSITY REDUCTIONS IN
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS.
UNDER THE ACT WHEN A PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT COMPLIES WITH
OBJECTIVE PLANNING RULES THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT DENY THE
PROJECT OR REDUCE ITS DENSITY
UNLESS IT MAKES A FINDING THAT
THE PROJECT WOULD HAVE A
SPECIFIC ADVERSE IMPACT. ON
PUBLIC HEALTH OR SAFETY THAT
CANNOT OTHERWISE BE MITIGATED.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE REQUIRED
HOUSING PROJECTS TO OBTAIN
REZONING SORE VARIANCES ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS.
EVEN ON THOSE PROJECTS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH HOUSING
DENSITIES AND OTHER OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS.
THESE TYPES OF REZONING IS ARE
VARIANCES ARE AWAY FROM LOCALS
TO EVADE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
ACT.
ON THE GROUNDS THAT PROJECTS ARE
SUBSEQUENTLY INCONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING ZONING STANDARDS.
CONSISTENT WITH SEVERAL BILLS
ENACTED INTO LAW LAST YEAR THIS
BILL STRENGTHENS.
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTED
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT BY CLOSING
LOOPHOLES THAT UNDERMINE THE
LAWS
APPLICABILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE SPONSOR AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GROUPS TO TRY TO FIND COMPROMISE
LANGUAGE FOR THIS BILL. WHICH
SEEKS TO UPHOLD THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE ACT TO ENSURE THAT
MORE HOUSING GETS BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A CHALLENGING SUBJECT.
BUT TO I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK
TWO OF ESTABLISH HIGHER
STANDARDS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ADHERE TO AS THEY CONSIDER
HOUSING PROJECTS.
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS AARON GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND YES THIS BILL AS I
WAS SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
AN EFFORT TO REINVIGORATE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WHICH
WAS INTENDED. TO SPUR.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WHICH WE ARE
GREATLY IN NEED OF OUTWARD VERY
THANKFUL TO MISTER DALY FOR
LEADING THE CHARGE ON THIS AND.
JUST TO UNDERSCORE THE INTENT
OVER THE YEARS SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THERE'VE BEEN.
MANY INSTANCES WHERE THE ACT IS
EASILY CIRCUMVENTED SO WE'RE
TRYING TO CLOSE LOOPHOLES TO
REALLY GET BACK TO THE INTENT OF
THE HOUSING COUNT ABILITY ACT.
AND AND TO ECHO OF THE AUTHOR WE
ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
OPPONENTS TO YOU KNOW ADDRESS
SOME OTHER ISSUES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AND IT'S NOT OUR INTENT
TO.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE ISSUES
ESPECIALLY REGARDING THE IMPACT
ON RURAL COMMUNITIES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND.
.
IN THE INTEREST OF BREVITY WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DESERVED ONE
ELSE'S PART OF THE BILL.
I DEMOCRATS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ADAM RIDLEY A BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO SUPPORT THANKS.
SEAN DOES THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS OFTEN SPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN OF
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE ON
WITNESSES AND OTHER OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CLOSELY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. I'M RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
TO CONTINUE WORKING. I'M WITH US
AND WE THINK WE'VE ACTUALLY
OUTLINED A FAIR COMPROMISE ON
INCLUDED IN YOUR ANALYSIS TODAY.
I'M BUT ESSENTIALLY ARE OUR
PROBLEM IS KIND OF WITH THE CORE
PREMISE OF THE BILL WHICH IS
BASICALLY THAT THE GENERAL PLAN.
SHOULD FUNCTION AS THE ZONING
CODE AND WE THINK THAT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE WAY
GENERAL PLANS ARE CONSTRUCTED IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS AND THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE INTENDED TO
BE A VERY LONG TERM PLAN. THERE
IS GOING TO BE A SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE A PARCEL
MAYBE ZONED AT LOW DENSITY AND
BE INCLUDED WITHIN A MUCH
BROADER RANGE OF DENSITY. IN THE
LONG RANGE PLAN FOR THE COUNTY
OR FOR THE CITY AND SO FOR THAT
REASON WE THINK THAT IT'S MUCH
BETTER RATHER THAN FOCUSING IN
SAYING. THAT LONG TERM PLAN
SHOULD SHOULD SERVE AS THE DE
FACTO ZONING CODE IS THAT WHEN
WE HAVE SET OUT THE AREAS ON A
PARCEL BY PARCEL BASIS IN OUR
HOUSING ELEMENTS. AND SAID THIS
IS WHERE WE WANT HOUSING GROWTH
TO HAPPEN AT THESE DENSITIES
THEN THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THAT. GENERAL
PLAN LEVEL DENSITY INSTEAD OF
WHAT'S IN THE ZONING CODE BUT
JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS ZONED
AT A LOW DENSITY DOESN'T MEAN
THAT IT SHOULD YOU KNOW BE TO
FACTO UP STONES. AND BECAUSE
IT'S IN THE SAME CATEGORY AS A
HIGHER DENSITY PARCEL IN THE
GENERAL PLAN AND SAW GIVEN
EXAMPLE ABOUT WHERE THAT
MATTERS.
IN THE UNINCORPORATED SOUND SO
IN A LOT OF RURAL COUNTIES
ZONING IS BASED ON PARCEL SIZES
AND SO FOR INSTANCE. I WON
COUNTY I WAS TALKING TO ABOUT
THIS BILL HAS IS ADEPT LAND USE
DESIGNATION THAT RANGES FROM
FIVE TO FORTY ACRE ZONING AND SO
FOR INSTANCE. UNDER THIS BILL.
THAT ZONING FOR WHAT WOULD
CURRENTLY BE A FORTY ACRE PARCEL
AND ALLOW PERHAPS ONE
RESIDENTIAL UNIT WOULD NOW HAVE
TO BE APPROVED. BY THE LOCAL
AGENCY TO ALLOW EIGHT FIVE ACRE
PARCELS AND SO THE ZONING WASN'T
SET UP WITH THE INTENT OF
ALLOWING HIGHER DENSITY USE ON
THOSE LARGER PARCELS IN THE MORE
RURAL AREAS AND SO. WE THINK
WHAT THIS IS REALLY CREATING IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LEAPFROG
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S INCONSISTENT
WITH THE BROADER LAND USE
POLICIES OF THE COUNTY OR THE
CITY AND SO. FOR THAT REASON WE
PROPOSE NARROWING IT AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE ANY GEORGE
REPRESENTING AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION.
WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
OF SEE SEPARATE THIS ISN'T JUST
AN URBAN OR RURAL COUNTY ISSUE.
THEY HOUSING ELEMENT ITSELF IS
REALLY DESIGNED TO SHOW. THE
DEVELOPERS THE JURISDICTION
WHERE YOU GONNA GROW AND WE'RE
GONNA GO NEXT
SO ALL THE SERVICES CONSISTENT
WITH S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE
ALL YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE
IN PLACE AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TO GROW. NEXT THE GENERAL PLAN
IN THE LAND USE ELEMENT ARE UP
TO THIRTY YEARS OUT IN BROADER
NOW. SO THEY MAY SAY WE'RE GONNA
GO HERE NOW BUT THIS LAYER IS
THE NEXT ONE WILL GROWTH WE NEED
TO. OF A ONE DO DENSITY FIRST IN
THE INFILL. AND THEN THIS IS
GOING TO BE TWENTY YEARS OUT
THIS IS GONNA BE THIRTY YEARS
OUT. WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE YOU
WOULD HAVE TO DO A REZONING THEY
COULD LEAPFROG TO HEAR.
AND EVEN IF IT'S CITY CITY CITY
AND THEN ANNEXED PARCELS HERE.
WE DON'T WANT TO JUMP AHEAD OF
S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND
WHERE ALL THE SERVICES ARE. SOLD
FOR US THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE AND
WE DON'T MIND CONTINUE WORK WE
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO DO THAT FAIRLY SOON BECAUSE
THIS IS CONTINUING WITH THE SAME
PROBABLY THAT WITH THE ORIGINAL
BELL. ON THE SECOND PIECE THE
BILL I JUST WANT TO MENTION
QUICKLY WAS INTENT LANGUAGE
DEALING WITH A SPECIFIC ADVERSE
IMPACTS.
THE LANGUAGE IS NOT CLEAR IT
HAS DEFINITIONS THAT ARE NOT
DEFINED WE DON'T WANNA HAVE TO
GO TO COURT TO IDENTIFY HOW WE
USE THAT. BECAUSE IT'S INTENT
LANGUAGE IT IS NOT STATUTORY
LANGUAGE SO WE THINK THE
EXISTING ADVERSE IMPACT.
LANGUAGE IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
USE RIGHT NOW IT'S REALLY DOWN
THE FIRE FLOOD AND. ANYTHING
ELSE IS A NATURAL DISASTER BUT
IF WE NEED IT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO USE IT SO THAT I THINK YOU
THERE HAS TO BE REMOVED OR
SUBSTANTIALLY REFINED. BUT WE'RE
STILL NOT CLEAR WHY THE EXISTING
STATUTE WHICH IS VERY SPECIFIC
AND VERY DIFFICULT TO USE IS AN
ADEQUATE OF THE BILLS THAT WE
OUGHT STILL OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TRACY RARE O'CONNOR REPRESENTS A
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO IMPOSE LESS MINUTE FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU THANK
YOU.%
TILLMAN ABORTIVE URBAN CARRIES A
CALIFORNIA ALSO IMPOSE LESS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WATER WOULD YOU
LIKE YOU JUST. JUST TRYING TO
CLARIFY OIL THOUGH SO.
I FIGURE I CAN GO OFF MY
EXPERIENCE AS A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
.
YOU KNOW THE WAY THEY ARE CITY
WAS DESIGNED IN TWO YEARS.
SO THAT AS IT WENT OUT. WAS MORE
RURAL.
SUBURBAN AND URBAN URBAN CORE.
.
SO BASICALLY THIS WOULD ALLOW.
HIGH DENSITY TO.
EVEN IF THE NEXT PARCEL OVER WAS
NOT ZONED AT THE SAME DENSITY IS
THIS ONE.
IT COULD ACTUALLY GO OUT INTO
THAT AREA.
AND BE THE SAME ZONING IS THE
ONE ADJACENT.
I THINK IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE
LANGUAGE IN THE GENERAL PLAN.
AND THE HOUSING ELEMENT.
IN THAT CITY.
THE OTHER LOT OF OTHER FACTORS
ARM I DON'T WANNA SAY THAT THAT
COULD NOT HAPPEN ABSOLUTELY BUT
IT IS
IT.
SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
IT SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
AN I WANT TO JUST COMMENT ON
THEM. ON ON WHAT WAS SAID.
BY WILL ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH.
THOSE WHO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
SOME OF THE DEFINITIONS.
AND THE VERY POINT THAT YOU'RE
RAISING WHICH IS THE.
THE.
.
WHAT THEY SAY IS THE POSSIBILITY
OF LEAP FROG THE DEVELOPMENT?
I THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE
DEFINITIONS AND IT DEPENDS ON
THE GENERAL PLAN AND THE HOUSING
ELEMENT SO THEY ALL THEY ALL ARE
SUPPOSED TO WORK.
BOB.
IN A COMPLEMENTARY FASHION.
IF THEY DON'T.
A JURISDICTION IN MY OPINION THE
JURISDICTION MAYBE HAS TO
REVISIT ITS OWN DOCUMENTS.
BUT THIS IS WHY WE HAVE I
HOUSING CRISIS IS BECAUSE A LOT
OF JURISDICTIONS THESE. THESE
PLANS
DON'T ARE NOT COMPLEMENTARY.
AND WE WE WANT THEM TO BE
COMPLIMENTARY.
AND SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO TO.
.
TO PASS LAWS THAT THAT
ENCOURAGED THAT I THINK IS A
GOOD IDEA.
SO.
YEAH NAM.
THE COURSE LEAPFROG DEVELOPMENT.
.
IS A PRETTY BROAD PHRASE TO ME
HOW MANY UNITS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT ULTIMATELY.
ME WE NEED A LOT MORE UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS WHY WE
DON'T ALWAYS GET THEM.
BECAUSE JURISDICTIONS DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF INCENTIVES TO GET THEIR
PLANNING ACTS.
ORGANIZED IT IS EXPENSIVE FOR
INSTANCE FOR GENERAL OF YOU KNOW
TO UPDATE A GENERAL PLAN OR
UPDATE HOUSING ELEMENT
COSTS MONEY.
AND.
SOME LOCAL JURISDICTIONS KEEP
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
BECAUSE.
DAY.
I DON'T SEE IT AS A PRIORITY. TO
HAVE THEIR HAVE THEIR.
THEIR GENERAL PLAN HOUSING
ELEMENT LAND USE ELEMENT
TRANSPORTATION ELEMENT AND SO
FORTH ALL IN SYNC.
THAT'S A LONG WINDED ANSWER A
MISS WALDRON BUT SOME.
I WANT THIS.
BILL TO IMPROVE THE PLANNING
PROCESS.
NOT.
OPEN THE DOOR TO BAD PLANNING
MINE.
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE HAD WITH
OUR TEARS WAS THAT. WE ONLY
WOULD YOU KNOW LOOK TO.
BUILD AT
THE DENSITY IN THE GENERAL PLAN
WHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE WAS
AVAILABLE.
WHICH WAS OUR. GOAL OF NOT.
NINA PREVENTING THE LEAPFROG.
.
SO IF YOU HAVE ZONING AND
ADJACENT AREAS ORINDA DIFFERENCE
OWN LEVEL.
BUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT
THERE AND IT'S NOT JUST SEWER
AND WATER COULD BE POLICE FIRE
SERVICE AND ALL THOSE THINGS
THOSE ARE AN ISSUE. THAT THE
CITY.
HAS TO LOOK AT WHEN IT'S
PLANNING.
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW. JUST WHAT
THE OPPONENT OPPONENTS WAS
SAYING KIND OF RAISE THAT
CONCERN TO ME THAT.
YOU KNOW IF THIS IS GOING TO.
RESULT IN OF GENERAL PLANS
ALLOWING HIGH DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT INTO AREAS THAT
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AREA.
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN WITH THE
PROJECT HAVE TO SIT AND WAIT.
UNTIL THAT'S AVAILABLE OUR HOUSE
AND YOU KNOW.
I THINK PART OF THE PROBLEM
WHERE. MY CITY IN JUST COULD
COME OFF MY EXPERIENCE BEING AN
OLDER CITY AT. PRETTY MUCH BILLS
OUT BUT YET IN THESE HOUSING
ELEMENTS IN THESE YOU KNOW ALL
OF THE REGIONAL PLANNING
AGENCIES ALWAYS TRYING TO PUT
MORE HOUSING IN. THEN YOU COULD
REALLY FIT AND.
THESE OLDER CITIES WANT TO DO
INFILL THEY DON'T WANNA GO OUT
INTO THESE OTHER AREAS SO.
IT'S KIND OF A BALANCING ACT
I PROMISE YOU I WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE OPPONENTS TO.
TO RESOLVE THAT ISSUE.
AND THE ALL STAY IN TOUCH WITH
THIS COMMITTEE TO. BUT BUT TO DO
THAT.
I'M I DON'T THINK I MEAN I.
YEAH THESE ARE THORNY ISSUES.
BUT IF WE DON'T. PUSH FORWARD.
I MEAN I I FEEL TO.
THE ME TO USE PLANNING.
AS AN EXCUSE.
TO NOT ALLOW HOUSING.
IS A PROBLEM ALSO.
SO WE'VE GOT A FIND A SWEET SPOT
WHERE WE ENCOURAGE MORE PLANNING
AND PLANS TO BE UP TO DATE OF
GENERAL PLANS.
R. ARE TOO FAR ADDED DATE THEY
ARE LONG TERM PLANNING
DOCUMENTS.
BUT WE NEED THEM TO REFLECT
TODAY'S REALITIES AS WELL.
SO THAT'S.
YOU KNOW THE USER THESE ARE VERY
COMPLICATED CONCEPTS BUT IN
PRACTICE AND I THINK MAYBE WE
NEED TO. HAVE SOME EXAMPLES FROM
SOME SPECIFIC EXAMPLES.
IF THERE ARE COUNTIES
THAT DON'T WANT DENSITIES IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THEIR COUNTIES
SAY THAT JUST SAY IT LOUD AND
CLEAR.
YOU KNOW YEAH.
I KNOW BECAUSE ARE THE CITY I
WASN'T RECENTLY UPDATED ITS
GENERAL PLAN AND IT WAS
LITERALLY A TEN YEAR PROCESS WHO
THEN BOWIE OTHER TALENTS NO IT'S
ARDUOUS IT'S. IT'S HARD IT'S IN
HOUSING ELEMENTS ARE
NOTORIOUSLY.
CHALLENGING.
AND IN THE STATE HAS A ROLE IN
HOUSING ELEMENTS TO.
AND ON AND ON BUT I BOMB I WAS
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR A
FOURTEEN YEARS NAM.
AND.
I A.
CAREA LOT ABOUT GOOD PLANNING
RATIONAL PLANNING SO PEOPLE HAVE
PREDICTABILITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
MUST BE AVAILABLE.
SO WE'LL DO OUR BEST TO.
AT DEEPER CONVERSATIONS WITH
THESE FOLKS ARE.
WITH THE PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND.
THE CAT WITH D. AND C. SACK.
AND. I TRY TO FIND A SWEET SPOT.
SOME RECORD.
DEPECHE PERFECT WHEN IT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY BUDGETS
WAS SAY I.
I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
TOM BUT I DO THINK THIS IS A
VERY. VERY IMPORTANT CONSCIOUS
HAVE VERY COMPLICATED ONE.
WE HAVE ZONING WE HAVE THE
GENERAL PLANNED LAW.
WE ADDED.
.
AS WAS ALLUDED TO SP THREE
SEVENTY FIVE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES.
WHICH SUPPORTS MORE COMPACT
DEVELOPED LET'S A JOURNAL PART
OF OUR RESPONSE TO GLOBAL
WARMING.
THAT'S A NEW OVERLAY.
THAT HAS KIND OF FORCED
COMMUNITIES TO KIND OF A LINE
THERE GENERAL PLANS WITH THE
SUSTAINABLE.
COMMUNITY SO THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME PRESSURES ALREADY.
IT'S NOT JUST YOU GOT THE ZONING
AND THE GENERAL PLAN AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL BUT YOU YOU DO HAVE
SOME STATE POLICY THAT'S.
MOVE DAN.
AND SO SOME OF THESE PIECES
START ALIGNING.
AND SO THIS ISSUE OF LEAPFROG
DEVELOPMENT ACTUALLY DOES TIE
INTO S. B. THROUGH SEVENTY FIVE
AND HOW ALL THE PIECES FIT
TOGETHER.
IT'S ACTUALLY VERY COMPLICATED
FIELD HEARINGS CHECK ON A
COUNTY.
IF YOU HOP IN A CAR. AT
THE EAST MOST NEIGHBORHOOD IN
RANCHO CORDOVA.
AND DR TO THE URBAN SERVICES
BOUNDARY.
IN MY DISTRICT IT'S ABOUT A
TWENTY FIVE MINUTE DRIVE EAST.
AND THERE IS PEOPLE WHO BOUGHT A
LOT OF THIS. ACREAGE UP BY THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS IN THE
EIGHTIES.
AND SOME OF THESE FOLKS Y.
BOUGHT THIS LAND ANTICIPATING
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEN THINGS HAVE CHANGED IN
THE INNER MEANING TIMES.
SO YOU COULD HAVE SOME FOLKS WHO
HAVE THIS PROPERTY WOULD LIKE TO
GET IN DEVELOPMENTS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE TIME IS
ON THEIR MONEY IS WASTED.
SO I'D.
I THINK THE FOCUS OF THE BILL ON
ZONING IN THE GENERAL PLAN IS A
GOOD THING THE CHICK WE GOTTA
KEEP IN MIND THAT THEY ACTUALLY
THE STATUS ENUNCIATED ITS OWN.
LAYER POLICY.
THE SUPPORT FOR THIS.
FAVORING COMPACT ENVELOPMENT IN
AVOIDING LEAPFROG DEVELOPMENT.
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF. A
LOT OF POLICY THAT'S OUT HERE.
AND.
.
WE GOTTA KINDA NOT JUST FOCUS ON
THE LOCAL STUFF BUT HOW IT FEELS
TO THE STATE.
RELEVANT STATUTE.
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION I
TAKE VERY VERY SERIOUSLY AND I
WANT TO RESOLVE THEM.
AND.
I THINK IT'S WORTH.
THIS IS A A CHALLENGE WORTH
PURSUING.
AND.
MAMA DO MY BEST TO FIND THE
SWEET SPOT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES IS A
SOLANO HERRERA.
I ACTUALLY.
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION OTHER
THAN THAT AND THEN I HAVE A
COMMENT IS.
.
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE I THINK THAT
THE CHALLENGES.
THAT.
WOULD YOU KNOW WHAT WORKS BETTER
THE CARRIER THE STICK.
AND.
WE ALWAYS END UP COMING HERE IN.
PASSING LEGISLATION BECAUSE
THERE'S ABOUT ACTOR OUT THERE
THAT.
OR MAYBE UP A LOT ABOUT ACTORS
RIGHT THERE'S A LOTTA NIMBIS OUT
THERE THAT JUST THEY REALLY
DELVE TELL YOU I'M FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I WANT
HOUSING AND THEN THE MINUTE YOU
START PROPOSING IT. THERE'S NOT
A GOODS GOOD PLACE FOR IT AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS WHOLE
AREA IS SET UP TO DO.
AND THEN AT SOME POINT.
I'M GONNA SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY I THINK EVEN IF THEY'RE
SOME WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I THINK IT'S.
THERE I CAN THINK OF LANGUAGE
THAT WORKS TO DEAL WITH THAT
THIS.
THE IS NOT TO BE USED AS A TO
LEAPFROG VACANT PARCELS ALONG
THE WAY. ON.
BUT BUT AT SOME POINT I THINK WE
NEED TO GET TO A POINT WHERE WE
SAY YOU HAVE TO HAVE A.
HOUSING ELEMENT THAT'S CURRENT
AND APPROVED YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
GENERAL PLAN IT'S AT LEAST WITH
THE NEXT NUMBER OF YEARS SO
THEY'VE LOOKED AT IT RECENTLY
AND. AND THEN WORK ON IT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR ZONING
ORDINANCE OF UP TO.
TWO IT THAT CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
GENERAL PLANNING YOUR HOUSING
ELEMENT.
AND IF YOU DO ALL OF THAT YOUR
FIRST IN LINE FOR STATE MONEY
AND IF YOU DON'T IF YOU'RE NOT
DOING ANY OF THOSE IF YOU IF IF
THERE'S ANY OF THOSE ARE
DEFICIENT YOU KNOW GETS.
RESOURCES TO BUILD.
BOTH IN TERMS OF ROADS
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE THOSE
THAT ARE DOING ALL OF THAT. AND
THAT ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING THE
RENO NUMBER. SHOULD BE FIRST IN
LINE AND THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
ARE GOING TO RESIST IT TO THE
END AND IF THEY WANT TO RESIST
IT THAT'S FINE BUT THEN THERE'S
NO OTHER STATE RESOURCES TO
COME.
COME THEIR WAY AND IT JUST IT
MAKES THE GOOD GUYS. GIVES THEM
THE CARROTS A NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE DOING THE GOOD THINGS I
THINK AND SO.
I AM. I AM A BIG BELIEVER THAT
THE CARROTS GET YOU MOVING A LOT
FASTER THAN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO.
SMACK EVERYBODY UPSIDE THE HEAD
THAT'S NOT DOING WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO. UP AND THEN
ALLOWING.
KIND OF A PUNITIVE TYPE OF OF.
.
PROCESS RATHER THAN MAKE IT
BECAUSE IT'S GOT MORE MORE
COMPLICATED WHEN YOU START
ADDING DENSITY BONUSES AND TODAY
WE'LL LOOK AT WILL LOOK AT THAT
FLOOR AREA RATIO IS AND KNOW ALL
THESE THINGS THAT. CREATE A
COMPLICATED.
MATRIX
THAT A LITTLE BIT AND PHAM
REALLY WHAT WE WANT IS BUILDING.
THOUGH I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE TODAY AND I'M
I'M SUPPORTIVE AND I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GET TO THAT.
AMENDMENTS NECESSARY TO MAKE
THIS WORK A LOT BETTER GOOD
THANK YOU THANK.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
LET'S MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU.
FOR A MOTION A SECOND SO MEMBER
COOLEY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
A WALL RENEW MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPONENTS VERY IMPORTANT POINTS
HAVE BEEN RAISED I TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY AND I'LL KEEP WORKING
ON THEM. I'VE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND I APPRECIATE WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THIS SOME THERE ARE SOME
A LOOP HOLES WITH THIS.
OF THE HOUSING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND I THINK.
.
IT'S TIME THAT WE ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE IT'S FRUSTRATING IT'S
TIME CONSUMING. BUT IF YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO WORK ON THIS.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOU FOR THE
OPPOSITION HAS SOME VERY GOOD
POINTS
AS WELL DOES YOUR SUPPORTER SO.
GREEN EYES TO GUYS AS YOU SAID
BY REACH OF SWEET SPOT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I WILL SUPPORT A
BILL TODAY.
SECRETARY CULTURALPROMOTION IS
DO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY. AGAR CURRY
I WALDRON.
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE COVEY ARROW
COME HERE I COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MULLIN PHOTO.
VOEPEL I.
SENATE.
MOTIONS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR VERY WELL
THANK YOU.
I WILL NEXT AS ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. NINETEEN HUNDREDS. OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO. AND WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY HIS SECOND ITEM ON
NUMBER NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PEROT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
EXTEND THE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THIS BILL PROVIDES
ECONOMIC SENATORS AND SEVEN TO
ENCOURAGE BUSINESS TO CREATE
BILL JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. AB
NINETEEN HUNDREDS OF FOCUSED
ECONOMIC INCENTIVE THAT WILL
HAVE A POSITIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA.
IT OFFERS A CHANCE TO SOLIDIFY
LOCAL COMMUNITY SUPPORT FOR
BUILDING A RETAINING A BUSINESS
WITH THE TAXABLE PROPERTY VALUE
ALONE REPRESENTS GREAT PUBLIC
REVENUE INCLUDING THE ADDITIONAL
CORPORATE AND PERSONAL TAX
COLLECTIONS.
EXTENDING THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE
PARTICULARLY REWARDING FOR
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS SUFFERED A
NEXUS.
OF CORPORATE HEADQUARTERS IN THE
LAST TWO DECADES.
SPECTRUM LOOK A LOCATION
SOLUTIONS IN IRVINE PRODUCER
REPORTS COVERING THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS AND FOUND NINE THOUSAND
CORPORATE. COMPANIES TO MOVE THE
HEADQUARTERS OBSERVER DIVERTED
PROJECTS TO OTHER STATES
WE ALL KNOW THE NAMES NESTLE
LOCKHEED MARTIN HERSHEY'S AND
NOW. WE HAVE TO READY AS A STATE
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE EASIER FOR
THEM LOCATE THEIR BUSINESSES AND
PRODUCTS INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA OTHERWISE WE CAN
EXPECT MORE THE SAME. THE INTENT
OF AB EIGHT NINETEEN HUNDRED IS
DIVERSE TO TRAVEL CALIFORNIA
SEES COMPANIES LEAVING THE
STATE.
AND TO ADDRESS AYE HEART
PROPERTY RATE AND UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE THAT IS HIGHER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE WE NEED GOOD
PAYING JOBS. NEAR TRACK TO
RETAIN THE EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE
THESE JOBS AND REVERSE REALITY
THAT WE ARE CONSIDERED AN
UNFRIENDLY BUSINESS STATE.
NINETEEN HUNDRED IS ONE WAY TO
HELP INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN
THESE INDUSTRY AND HIGH WAGE
JOBS MEMBERS WE CAN'T SIT ON THE
SIDELINES THIS IS A BUSINESS
FRIENDLY LOCALLY DRIVEN MEASURE.
AND AYE ASTRAEA AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT DRAW COOK CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES THAT SUPPORT
SING NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SARAH FLOCKS
IN THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
WE WERE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL IN PRINT BECAUSE OF THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM TO
RETAIL TRADE BUSINESSES OUTSIDE
OF MANUFACTURING.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IS THAT THE
AUTHOR IS TAKING ALL OF THE.
ACTIVITY AMENDMENTS.
THAT GROUP THAT WITH AYE THOSE
AMENDMENTS WE ARE GLAD TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION AND GO NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WINNIE AND IT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OF THE BILL.
GROWING AS AMENDED.
SECOND.
THERE WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
AND CIGARETTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS.
OKAY.
THEY FOR BRINGING THIS FOR AND
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION SO THANK YOU SOMEHOW
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING US
ON THE BILL APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU.
OKAY SECRETARY HOLBROOKE.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
ADWARE CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE BLOOM
KAVIR BLOOM AYE CABALLERO KABIRA
AYE COOLEY AYE AYE COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE LACKEY
LACKEY AYE MULLIN PHOTO. VOEPEL
BACK I.
OUT EIGHT ZERO.
OKAY LET'S WHO WANT YOUR NEXT
FILM OF ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWO
FIVE FIVE EIGHT.
AND THE.
COME ON UP AND JOIN IN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
EXTENDS PROTECTIONS VOTERS AND
TAXPAYERS THAT ENSURING THAT ANY
CONSOLIDATION OF THE OFFICES
AUDIT CONTROLLER. OR TAX
TREASURER COLLECTION MUST BE
FIRST APPROVED BY A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE.
VOTERS MUST BE ASKED THE
QUESTION WHETHER THESE
CONSOLIDATED POSITIONS WILL BE
APPOINTED OR ELECTED AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT DOES NOT
INTERFERE WITH THE BILL YOU THE
BOARDS. OF SUPERVISORS AND FIND
FIVE COUNTY SPECIFIED IN
EXISTING LAW TO CONSOLIDATE
ORDER CONTROLLER TAX
TREASURER COLLECTOR AS AN
ELECTED POSITION AND WILL SIMPLY
PROVIDECONSISTENCY. ACROSS
REMAINING CALIFORNIA VOTERS THE
BILL ENSURES AT THE MONEY
TAXPAYERS PUT IN THE HANDS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND MANAGED TO
THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
INTEGRITY. PROFESSIONAL AND
IMPARTIALITY THANK YOU AND I
RESPECT LAST SURVIVOR. WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS THE
HONORABLE ERIC WOOLERY THE
AUDITOR CONTROL OF ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE HONORABLE KAREN ADAMS
THE TAX TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
OF MERCED COUNTY.
WELCOME TO HAVE.
MADAM CHAIR MADAM VICE CHAIR IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ERIC WOOLERY I AM A CO
SPONSOR A BABY TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT. AS THE INDEPENDENTLY
ELECTED AUDITOR CONTROLLER
POINTS COUNTY MY OFFICE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVALUATING ALL
CLAIMS AND CHARGES SUBMITTED TO
THE COUNTY. AND FOR ISSUING ALL
COUNTY PAYMENTS.
THE THREAT OF MAKING MY OFFICE
APPOINTED AND THE THREAT OF
REPEALING MY CONTROLLER
FUNCTIONS SURFACED ON OCCASIONS
WHEN I EXERCISE THE AUDITOR
CONTROLLERS CHECK AND BALANCE
DUTIES WITH REGARD TO THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
FOR INSTANCE MY OFFICE DELAYED
PAYMENT ON HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER FUNDED
MAILERS THAT TWO MEMBERS OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WANTED TO SEND TO
THE VOTERS SHORTLY BEFORE THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTIONS.
I WANTED CLARENCE FROM THE F.
PPC ON THESE MAILERS.
THESE MAILERS ARE SO EGREGIOUS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE YOU
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED S. B. FORTY
FIVE WHICH THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
INTO LAW LAST YEAR. TO SEVERELY
RESTRICT THESE MAILERS.
AND ANOTHER INCIDENT AND SINCE
MY OFFICE ATTEMPTED TO WITHHOLD
A FOUR YEAR RETROACTIVE PENSION
PAYMENT FOR A THIRD MEMBER OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. WHILE WE SOUGHT
INFORMATION ON THE LEGALITY OF
THIS PAYMENT.
DURING BOTH OF THESE INSTANCES
INCIDENTS I LEARNED THAT FROM
MULTIPLE PEOPLE THAT MY. MAKING
MY OFFICE APPOINTED OR REPEALING
THE OFFICE FUNCTION WERE BOTH
EXPLORED.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY A CLOSES
THIS UNIQUE LOOPHOLE THAT ONLY
APPLIES TO CONSOLIDATING THE
APPOINTED DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
THE ELECTED AUDITOR CONTROLLER
AND THE ELECTED TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR.
IN ALL SEVEN INSTANCES IN THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS WHERE THESE
TYPES OF.
CONSOLIDATIONS WERE APPROVED.
THE VOTERS WERE NOT GIVEN THE
CHOICE AS WHETHER TO A
CONSOLIDATED OFFICE SHOULD BE
ELECTED OR APPOINTED.
THERE IS NO OTHER COUNTY OFFICE
IN WHICH EXISTING LAW ALLOWS AN
APPOINTED OFFICE TO BE COMBINED
WITH AN ELECTED OFFICE WITHOUT
REQUIRING THE VOTERS TO DECIDE
WHETHER THE OFFICES ELECTED OR
APPOINTED.
FOR EXAMPLE THE CLERK COUNTY
CLERK CANNOT BE CONSOLIDATED
WITH AN APPOINTED OFFICE AND
LESS THE CONSOLIDATED OFFICE
REMAINS ELECTED OR THE PEOPLE
HAVE A SEPARATE VOTE TO MAKE
THE.
COUNTY CLERK APPOINTED.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY A DOES NOT
ALTER EXISTING LAW REGARDING THE
ABILITY OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO CONSOLIDATE
ELECTED OFFICES WITH OTHER
ELECTED OFFICES.
THIS SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT IF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WISHES TO
CONSOLIDATE ELECTIVE OFFICES.
WITH THE APPOINTED OFFICE OF
DIRECTOR FINANCE THEN THE VOTERS
MUST BE ABLE TO DECIDE WHETHER
TO THE CONSOLIDATED OFFICE IS
ELECTED OR APPOINTED.
THE AUTO LA ALREADY REQUIRES
THAT SWITCHING AN AUDITOR
CONTROLLER FROM ELECTED TO
APPOINTED REQUIRES A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE.
AND IT HAS THE EXACT SAME
REQUIREMENT FOR A TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT FIXES
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
CONSOLIDATION LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS AN END RUN AROUND THIS
REQUIREMENT.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT IF A
COUNTY WISHES TO HAVE A
CONTROLLER FUNCTION IT MUST BE
HELD BY THE AUDITOR. HOWEVER THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CAN ABOLISH
THE CONTROLLER FUNCTION BY A
SIMPLE MAJORITY VOTE.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
INSURES THAT THE CONTROLLER
FUNCTION IS GOING TO BE
ABOLISHED.
FROM THE AUTHOR ELECTED AUDITOR
CONTROLLER IT SHOULD ONLY BE
DONE BY A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE COUNTY NOT MERELY BY THREE
VOTES OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M KAREN ADAMS.
AND I'M PRIVILEGED TO BE OF THE
MERCED COUNTY TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR HAVE SERVE FOR THE
LAST SIXTEEN YEARS I'M HERE TO
VOICE STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR A BE TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY TREASURERS
AND TAX COLLECTORS.
THIS MEASURE SUPPORTABLE FOR
THREE IMPORTANT REASONS FIRST
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT VOTERS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE IF IT IS
IN THEIR BEST INTEREST TO LOOSEN
ELECT A FOR EFFORT
REPRESENTATIVE ONE WHO HAS
DIRECT ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE
TAXPAYERS. REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
SHOULD REQUIRE A VOTE THE
ARGUMENT THE VOTERS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOICE THEIR OBJECTION
AT OPEN BOARD MEETING. FAILS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MANY VOTERS
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO FOLLOW
THE PORTA SUPERVISORS CLOSELY
ENOUGH. TO KNOW WHEN THEY ARE
CONSOLIDATE CONSIDERING THE
REMOVAL OF AN ELECTED OFFICE.
AND TO CONSOLIDATE THAT POWER TO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VOTERS
SHOULD GET A VOTE AND NOT JUST
READ ABOUT IT PERHAPS AFTER THE
FACT IN ADDITION VOICING A
OBJECTION DOES NOT INSURE IN
ACTION TO CONSOLIDATE. WILL NOT
BE APPROVED AS ILLUSTRATED IN MY
PERSONAL VOICE IN OBJECTION TO A
CONSOLIDATION AS MY STATUS IS
ELECTED TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
AND I OBJECTED AND OPEN BOARD
MEETING AND REQUEST FULLY. THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOLLOWED
WITH UNANIMOUS VOTE TO
CONSOLIDATE THEIR FOR VOTE THAT
OF VOICING OUR A OPPOSING.
ARGUMENT DOES NOT PROVIDE AN
ACTIVE A CLEAR STATEMENT FOR
VOTERS ONLY AND ELECTION DOES
THAT.
SECOND AS TREASURE TAX
COLLECTORS WE REALIZE THAT WE
ARE NOT ALWAYS WELL KNOWN TO THE
VOTERS WE WORK BEHIND THE SCENES
PRUDENTLY INVESTING ALL
COLLECTED COUNTY WIDE MONIES. IN
ADDITION TO PROPERTY TAX DOLLARS
AND MOST VOTERS TO NOT REALIZE
THAT WE SERVE AS THEIR TAXPAYER
ADVOCATE.
AS A CURRENT EXAMPLE YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO PROTECT
TAXPAYERS STATEWIDE BY PUSHING
FOR THE STRONGEST CONSUMER
PROTECTION RELATED TO THE PACE
INDUSTRY.
IT WOULD BE MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
FOR TAX COLLECTORS TO TAKE A
PROMINENT ROLE IN THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE IF WE WERE ACCOUNTABLE TO
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS WHO HAVE
BEEN ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE. OF
THE PACE LEGISLATION IN RECENT
HISTORY.
FURTHER THE CONSOLIDATION
TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR AN
AUDITOR CONTROLLER WAS REVIEWED
BY THE SENATE IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN. AND IT WAS EVIDENT THAT AND
IN COMPUTER INCOMPATIBILITY OF
OFFICES DOES SO EXIST.
BETWEEN THE AUDITOR AND
TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
FUNCTIONS AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
ENTRUSTED WITH THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY MY ACTIONS MUST HAVE
OVERSIGHT. AND A CONSOLIDATION
OF THE AUDITOR CONTROLLER AND
TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR OF WROTE
THAT TAXPAYER PROTECTION.
AS A RESULT CONSOLIDATIONS DO
NOT SAVE MONEY BECAUSE OUTSIDE
AUDITORS MUST BE HIGHER TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
INTEGRITY IN THE OFFICE.
AND FINAL AS A POINT OF PRIDE.
AND AND THE MERCED COUNTY.
EXCUSE ME AND FINALLY AS A
POINT OF PRIDE COUNTY TREASURER
TAX COLLECTORS HAVE BEEN DEFINES
LOCAL STATE AND NATIONAL TO
SYSTEM STATISTICS WHEN IT COMES
TO GENDER PROFILE OF ELECTED
OFFICE.
IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN HOLD THE
MAJORITY OF ELECTED COUNTY
TREASURER TAX COLLECTORS AND WE
ARE DATING PROUD OF IT.
BUT WE'VE NOTED DURING RECENT
CONSOLIDATIONS MEN HAVE REPLACED
THE WOMEN THROUGH CONSOLIDATE
ROLE AS AUDITOR. IN.
AND IN THE MOST RECENT ATTEMPTS
TO CONSOLIDATE THE TWO WOMEN
THAT WERE BEING CONSIDERED FOR
CONSOLIDATION.
AT VERY A THEIR AUDITORS WERE
NOT SO THEREFORE THERE'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY RUN
GRAMMAR WOMEN HAVE A HIGHER
SUCCESS BEING ELECTED TREASURER
TAX COLLECTOR IN WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND FINALLY CLOSING
AS A PROUD PAST PRESENT A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS. I URGE YOU TO
PRESERVE THE RIGHT TO THE VOTERS
TO DETERMINE WHAT'S BEST IN
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
THEIR BALLOT BOX.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT IS BEST FOR VOTERS AND
TAXPAYERS AND IT WILL SEND A
STRONG MESSAGE THAT WE ARE ALL.
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING THE
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TOUGH ONE TO FOLLOW.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NOTS I
REALLY HAVE THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY AUDITOR'S
OUGHT TO ALL THE COMMENTS MADE
EARLIER ENERGY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I'M BRIDGET HEAVILY ON THE OTHER
TO CONTROL FOR YUBA COUNTY AND I
WANNA ECHO MY SUPPORT FOR THE OF
THE COMMENTS HERE AND URGE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF BERGMAN
TURKEY I ARE CONTROLLING HERE'S
FOR THE BILL THINKING.
HELLO I'M REBEKAH CALLAN AUDITOR
CONTROLLER FOR THE COUNTY OF
CALAVERAS AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DURING THE JOHNSON OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND ALSO BEHALF MY
COLLEAGUE WITH THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
AYE WE DO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE WE FEEL UNDERMINES
THE GIVEN AUTHORITY TO THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS TO MAKE DECISIONS
WHERE GREATER EFFICIENCY CAN BE
ACHIEVED IN THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN OUR RURAL COUNTIES.
YOU KNOW I I WANT TO TAKE A STEP
BACK TO LOOK AT THE BIGGER
PICTURE.
ABOUT THE CHANGE OF THESE NON
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS THESE IS
ONE OF MANY LEGISLATIVE ATTEMPTS
WE'VE SEEN.
I TO ESTABLISH GREATER AUTHORITY
FOR NON CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
TO MAKE THEM. MORE LIKE THE
SHERIFF THE ASSESSOR THE DA AND
OTHERS WHO'VE GONE TO THE
VOTERS.
AND A HOLISTIC WAY TO ASK SHOULD
ALL OF THESE AUTHORITIES BE
GRANTED TO THIS OFFICE
AND WE WOODS RESPECTFULLY
SUGGEST THAT THAT WOULD BE A
MORE APPROPRIATE WAY TO ENGAGE
WITH THE VOTERS.
IF THEIR OPINION IS SO SOUGHT
AND I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF VOTER ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS SPECIFIC CONSOLIDATION.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY DOES
PROVIDE FOR VOTER ENGAGEMENT
THEY CAN.
ISSUE ARE THEY CAN SEEK A
REFERENDUM TO UNDO THE ACTION OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IF THEY
DISAGREE WITH THE CONSOLIDATION
OF OFFICES SO. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU.
JOHN FORSYTHE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO I RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT. ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
THAT THE COUNTIES HAVE THIS
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS AUTHORITY IS
DURING ROUGH TIMES DURING THE
RECESSION WE REALLY HAD A. YOU
KNOW CONSOLIDATE AND THINK ABOUT
HOW TO MAKE THE MOST EFFICIENT
SERVICES SO WE JUST.
RESPECTFULLY BELIEVE THAT IT
SHOULD BE OUT AND WITHIN THE
PATROL THE BORDER SUPERVISORS
BECAUSE TIMES CHANGE THINGS
CHANGE ISSUES CHANGIN SHOULD BE
DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. VICTORY
OPPOSE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING MOTHERING COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
THE.
.
BECAUSE A FACILITY RECOVERY
ARROW AND SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WATER IF YOU HAVE
A QUESTION YEAH I JUST I IT IT'S
NOT A QUESTION I THINK IT'S JUST
THAT A COMMENT AND.
HAVE IN IT YOU KNOW I'M I'M A
BIG. BELIEVER IN LOCAL CONTROL
AND A BIG BELIEVER IN.
AND HAVING DELEGATING THAT
AUTHORITY DOUBTS AND MOST OF US
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO I
KNOW WE FEEL THE SAME WAY. BUT.
BUT THE IT THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AND IN HERE'S THE
REASON IS THAT THE AUDITORS HAVE
A REAL DIFFERENT FUNCTION. OUGHT
THEN THE CONTROLLERS ANDAND
THERE'S ME THE AUDITOR
CONTROLLER TREASURE.
CAN BE SEPARATE THINGS THAT
LOOK AT DIFFERENT.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES AND.
I HAD I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO A
REALLY TALKED TALKIN DAMP DEPTH
TO MY LOCAL.
MY LOCALS AND.
THEY THERE'S SOMETHING DO SHARE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE REALLY
INDEPENDENT FROM THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND. I'M SO ANYWAY I
I JUST THINK THAT.
THAT THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT SITUATION AND.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT.
IF I WAS SITTING AT THAT COUNTY
BOARDS WHO FOR IT VISOR I MIGHT
THINK LET ME MAKE THE DECISIONS
ON YOU KNOW WHAT I SHOULD
CONSOLIDATE WHAT WHEN I
SHOULDN'T BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT. ARE THERE THESE DUTIES ARE
SO DIFFERENT AND SO INDEPENDENT
THAT YEAH IT REALLY REQUIRES AT.
AS TO PROTECT THEM AND TO SET
THEM UP SO THAT IF IN FACT
THERE'S A CONSOLIDATION THAT'S
NECESSARY GOTOVO TO THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM MANY.
A CASE OF A JUDGE CLOSE.
REGISTER THANKS FOR THIS
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS BILL IN THIS IS
THAT I THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALL
THE ARROW HIT ON THE HEAD THIS
IS DIFFERENT AND YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE AN AUDITOR MAY
BE LOOKING AT A.
A BORDER SUPERVISOR ACTION AND
FIND SOMETHING AND WE FOUND AN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT.
OUR AUDITOR HAD TO USE COUNTY
COUNCIL. AND COUNTY COUNCILS
HARD BY THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
HE COULD NOT GET HIS OWN.
ANNA COUNTY COUNCIL TO LOOK
INTO THESE TO THESE ISSUES AND.
YOU KNOW THAT THE COUNTY
ATTORNEY'S BEHOLDEN TO THE BOARD
SUPRISING HIRAM SO ON TO INSURE
THEIR INDEPENDENCE
AND.
THEIR FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
TO OF THE TAXPAYERS THAT'S THE
REASON WE RAN THIS BILL AND I
RESPECT PLEASURABLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL
BE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL FOR
ALL THOSE REASONS.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
MULLIN VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
BILLS I'D EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAU WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD PROHIBIT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OR HEALTH
OFFICER. FROM BEING ACCOMPANIED
BY A PERSON WITH A POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL INTEREST IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE INSPECTION. A
WHEN INSPECTING A COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY OR BUSINESS ARE FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE
STATUTE REGULATION OR LOCAL
ORDINANCE.
BUSINESSES.
TYPICALLY GO THROUGH CODE
ENFORCEMENT INSPECTIONS TO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE SAFE HABITABLE AND
HEALTHY PLACES FOR THE PUBLIC.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER ALL HEALTH
OFFICER WILL INSPECT A BUSINESS
AND ISSUE CITATIONS FOR ANYTHING
THAT IS NOT UP TO PROPER SAFETY
LEVELS.
THE BUSINESS MUST AND FIX ANY
SITE ARE CITED ISSUES IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE A PERMIT TO OPERATE.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND ETHNIC NEWSPAPER IN MY
DISTRICT GOT DETAILED A
SITUATION WHERE THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WHILE
CONDUCTING. OUR INSPECTION OF AN
AUTO BODY FACTORY WAS A COMPANY
THANK YOU BY THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTOR WHO OPERATED THE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
BUSINESS.
UPRIGHT AGAINST BUT THE
INSPECTION THE BUSINESS OWNER
PREVIOUSLY HAD AN ARCHITECT
DESIGN THE PLANS FOR THE
RENOVATION TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE CITY'S COATS. HOWEVER THE
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICER CITED A
NUMBER OF ISSUES WITH THE
BUSINESS AND THE ARCHITECTURAL
PLAN AND REQUIRED THE BUSINESS
OWNER TO FIX THEM.
AFTER THE INSPECTION WAS
COMPLETED THE AND THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER LEFT THE
PREMISES. OF THE OWNER HAT WAS
APPROACH BY THE CONTRACTOR WHO
STAYED BEHIND AND OFFER TO
REDESIGN AND CONSTRUCT THE
PROJECT FOR THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THE BUSINESS OWNER WAS QUOTED TO
PAY ONLY TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS BY
THE INITIAL ARCHITECT.
THE BUSINESS OWNER ULTIMATELY
PAID THE CONTRACTOR HOOKED WHO
ACCOMPANIED THE CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OUT OF FEAR THAT NOT
DOING SO WOULD RESULT IN DELAYS
TO HAVING THE PERMIT APPROVED.
THE BUSINESS OWNER SUSPECTED.
I BEING THE SUBJECT OF A SCHEME
WHEREBY THE CONTRACTOR AND
ACTION THIS BILL. AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE LIMITS OF
SITUATIONS THAT WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WILL HEALTH
OFFICERS FROM BEING ACCOMPANIED.
BY THIRD PARTY INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS TO ONLY DOES WERE
OUR INDIVIDUAL IS THERE FOR
LEGITIMATE REASONS AND ONE NOT
FINANCIALLY BENEFIT FROM AYE
REMEDYING ANY OF THOSE ISSUES
FOUND DURING THE INSPECTION.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FURTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DRAW COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY SO
SHE'S XIN WHERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NOTHING QUESTIONS OF THE.
COMMITTEE.
YES ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH I I HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS
ALREADY ILLEGAL CONDUCT.
IT'S A. IT'S A.
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AND.
AND AND SHOULD BE.
IT.
IF.
I'M I BELIEVE IT'S HAPPENING BUT
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY WE
NEED TO MAKE IT.
A LAW.
IF IT'S ALREADY ILLEGAL CONDUCT
SURE ARE THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
OF PRIOR TO.
THE INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL IN
FACT WE HAD LET'S COUNCIL AND
ALSO. OF THE LEAGUE OF CITIES TO
LOOK INTO THIS THE POLITICAL
SITUATION TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
EXISTING LAW ALREADY COVERED
THIS SITUATION. THEY ALL CAME UP
AND EMPTY SURPRISINGLY ENOUGH.
AND OUT YOU KNOW YOU COULD POP
ACTUALLY ARE ARGUE THAT THIS IS
WITHIN THE REALM OF FAR A FRAUD
A MISREPRESENTATION NO
CORRUPTION CASES BUT BUT WE
LOOKED IN THERE'S NOTHING IN IT
ON THE BOOKS THAT THAT WOULD
COVER THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION.
ODD YOU KNOW I'VE ALSO HEARD
PERSONALLY AND OTHER SITUATION
ARE THAT HAPPEN IN MY DISTRICT
THIS COULD BE A SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS TO PRO PROBABLY
PRIMARILY TO THE ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES. ALL AS WELL.
IN MANY OF THESE CASES THE THE
THE THE BUSINESS OWNERS ARE NOT
WILLING TO STEP FORWARD TO
TESTIFY THAT'S ONE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES. AND. AN ENDLESS
WARS FRAUD SINCE AND I ALSO DID
A LITTLE RESEARCH ON THAT THAT
THE THE A CAUSE OF ACTION FOR
FRAUD ACTUALLY HAS FIVE ELEMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE FALSE MET MS
REPETITION OF OF MATERIAL FACT.
KNOWLEDGE OF FALSITY AND INTEND
TO RECEIVE REASONABLE RELIANCE
BY INNOCENT PARTY OR LOSS
SUFFERED BY THE PARTY STILL A
FRAUD MAY MAY NOT TO A
POTENTIALLY COVERED THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION. THAT WE
HAVE ON HAND AND THIS IS
HAPPENING A THREE I ACTUALLY
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT SAID SO
THAT'S WHY WE ARE INTRODUCED A
BILL.
YES.
AND DOES THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD BECAUSE IT IS
FRUSTRATING.
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE THAT'S
DOING INSPECTION WHO IS ALSO
QUALIFIED.
AND VERY WELL MAY BE THE ONE
DOING THE WORK AND I SAY THIS
FROM EXPERIENCE HAS AS A KIND
GENTLE CONTRACTOR.
AND THE WAY THE LOOPHOLE THE WAY
THEY'RE GETTING AWAY FROM IT
BEING FRAUD OR ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
IS BY THE CONTRACTOR STICKING
AROUND AFTERWARD PUTTING ON THE
DIFFERENT HAT NO LONGER BEING A
PART OF THE INSPECTION BUT NOW
BEING A PART OF THE SOLUTION
ALTHOUGH. THAT PERSON IS A PART
OF BOTH AND SO BY SEPARATE BY
DRAWING IN DELINEATING BETWEEN
THE INSPECTION VERSES THE.
ACTUAL CONTRACTING ON THE WORK
THAT'S THE LEUPOLD SO. THIS BILL
WOULD HELP CLARIFY THAT IF
YOU'RE A PART OF ONE YOU CAN'T
BE THE OTHER.
AND THAT'S JUST UP TO ME WOULD
BE COMMONSENSE SO THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS
AS WELL.
ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT THANK YOU MUCH HEY.
YOU KNOW I SOON SIMILAR
PROBLEMS AS WELL IN MY SMALL
COMMUNITY IN SO FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING IN SOME
UNSCRUPULOUS.
CONTRACTOR COMES THEN RIGHT ON
THE HEELS WITH INSPECTOR SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR AND
I'M QUITE SURPRISING THING IS IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO SAID.
IS IN THIS ALREADY OUT THERE AND
IT WASN'T SO THANKS VERY MUCH
UPSWING FOR.
SECRETARY TOOK THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AG WHERE
CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO CAVIAR AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
THERE'S OUT NINE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU EVERYONE
MEMBER CHAU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY WOULD YOU LIKE PRESENT.
ITEM NUMBER.
SUSIE FOR TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR.
GOOD.
A MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY PERCENT AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR. PARDON ME
A. RELATING TO LOOK OVER
NORTON'S ORDINANCES.
AND CANNABIS FINDS.
AS OF JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR CANNABIS IS NOW LEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA FOR MEDICAL USE AS
WELL AS ADULT USE. OVER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE.
WE ARE SETTING IN PLACE A
REGULATORY STRUCTURE.
ON THIS BUSINESS
AS WE DO SO THERE ARE CHALLENGES
ENTERS FOLKS WHO WON OPERATE
OUTSIDE THE LAW.
A JUST YESTERDAY MORNING I WAS
SITTING WITH RANCHERA COPS
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY SEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
CANNABIS IN THE CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA THEY SEE ILLEGAL GROWS.
IT HAS A REGULATORY CHALLENGES A
LAW ENFORCEMENT CHALLENGE.
.
AND.
A STATISTIC HERE OUR OUR SHARES
DEPARTMENT HAVE HAD HUNDREDS OF
CALLS IN THE LAST YEAR DEALING
WITH.
A ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROW
OPERATIONS
SEIZING PLANTS FINDING A.
POUNDS OF CANNABIS GUNS CASH ALL
KINDS OF THINGS AT THESE ILLEGAL
GROWS.
.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE IDENTIFY
WHEN HE SPOTS
AND THEY CAN HAVE A CITATION BUT
THEY CAN'T FOLLOW UP IMMEDIATELY
AND WHICH.
TIMELY ILLEGAL OPERATOR JUST.
MOVES THEIR.
CHAU ONTO A DIFFERENT VENUE.
EVEN EIGHTEEN OF FOLLOW THROUGH
COMPLICATED LOCAL ENFORCEMENT.
A AB TWENTY ONE SIXTYFORCE A
PERMISSIVE BILL WILL ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS
TO AMEND THEIR ORDINANCES.
REMOVE THE TIME PERIOD TO
CORRECT A VIOLATION.
IN CASES OF CANNABIS CULTIVATION
ONLY.
SO JUST ALLOW US IN THIS PERIOD
BEATING INTENSE ENFORCEMENT.
TO KIND OF SHORT CYCLE THE
CONSEQUENCE OF BEING CITED.
AND.
I THINK THEREFORE SUPPORT
STRONG REGULATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT FIELD LOCAL COMMITTEE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
A AND IT.
MAKES IT HARDER FOR PERSONS WANT
TO BE NON COMPLIANT REMAIN
NUNCA.
OF THE BILL SUPPORTIVE I CALPERS
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
COVER PLEASE USE A BROKEN RIB
SAM'S AND I URGE RIGHT VOTE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND MANY CHAIR MEMBER
GOOD AFTERNOON LUCIA MUCH LARA
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I'LL AT THE
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR A ONE I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY FOR.
AUTHORING THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH OUR ASSOCIATION TO
NARROW THE FOCUS ON THE BILL ON
ILLEGAL CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO THINK ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION WHO HAVE THAT
REACHED OUT TO US. AND OUT WE
HAD DISCUSSED ARE CONCERNED
ENOUGH KNOWLEDGE THAT ON SEE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY KNOW
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DIALOGUE WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR.
OPPOSITION AND OTHER CONCERNS
GET.
REMOVED UMPIRED AT TO DISPEL
MOVING FORWARD TO THE FLOOR I'M
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THINK YOUR OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. SING NINE OPPOSITE
THAT ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A DEBRA CARLTO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
A YOU KNOW WE AGREE WITH THE
APPROACH THAT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
NO PROBLEM IF YOU WISH TO
PROCEED AGAINST TENANTS IN
PARTICULAR. MANY OF OUR OWNERS I
WOULD SAY OLIVER OWNERS.
HAVE PROHIBITED THROUGH THEIR
LEASES I CANNABIS GROW AND WE
HAD WORKED WITH.
LEGISLATORS WHEN THIS
INITIATIVE WAS MOVE FORWARD AT
THE STATE LEVEL WHAT WE HAVE
PROPOSED IS SOMETHING WE BELIEVE
TO BE VERY REASONABLE SIMPLY
KEEP THE EXISTING STE OF LAW IN
PLACE AS IT PERTAINS TO.
PROPERTY OWNERS GIVE THEM THE
RIGHT TO APPEAL.
SO YOU DON'T CHANGE THE LAWS
THAT PERTAINS TO THEIR RIGHT TO.
SHOULD DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
HAD NO KNOWLEDGE AND DEMONSTRATE
THAT THEY HAVE IN FACT
PROHIBITED THAT ACTIVITY YOU CAN
STILL PROCEED WITH THE CHANGES
AS A PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AGAINST THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY.
VIOLATING THE STATUTE SO THAT'S
I BELIEVE TO BE A REASONABLE
APPROACH A TO MOVING FORWARD AND
WE WOULD REQUEST OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS A BE CONSIDERED
BEFORE YOU VOTE. ON THE BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MET THE
HEART WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
I WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
DEBORAH. ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE
THEIR SEVENTY TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT YOU CAN DO A COMMERCIAL
LEASE.
YEAH UNDERWAY THAT THIS BILL IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
IT WOULD PUT SOME OF THE ONUS ON
A LANDLORD PROPERTY OWNER TO BE
PICKING THROUGH YOUR WINDOWS TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE NOT DOING
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY THAT'S NOT THE.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING A POSITION
OUR OUR OWNERS WANT TO BE IN OUR
PROPERTY MANAGERS AND WE WOULD
JUST TAX THAT THERE IS A AT
LEAST THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THERE
SO WE CAN THERE CAN BE AN
APPEALS PROCESS. OR SOMETHING IN
THE LAW THAT RECOGNIZES THAT
THAT.
LANDLORDS AREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE
POLICING THEIR TENANTS IN THIS
MANNER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS A WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE AUTHOR STAFF.
AND WERE SEEKING A PROPOSED
AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT.
FINES AND PENALTIES ON RENTAL
PROPERTIES RELATED CANNABIS
CULTIVATION ARE LEVIED ON THE
ACTUAL TEN INTO IS LEASING THE
PROPERTY AND NOT PROPERTY OWNER.
AND.
WE'RE SEEING THIS AMENDMENT US
SO THAT IT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE SPIRIT OF THE.
RENTAL PROPERTY UNDER
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE PUT INTO
PLACE BY THE.
CANNABIS A LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
THAT WAS PASSED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND SO WE'RE CONFIDENT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT JUST WANT TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
SO
LISTENING QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
YES.
S. SUMMER PEREIRO. CONFIGURING
MUCH SO I APPRECIATE.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WITH?
THIS BILL MISTER COOLEY AYE. I
HAD.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE COMBINATION
OF OF A NUMBER OF COMMENTS.
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS READING IT
WASN'T CLEAR TO ME THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT COMMERCIAL
CULTIVATION AS OPPOSED TO THE
LEGAL CULTIVATION THAT'S
PERMITTED. UNDER THE LAW.
AND.
IN IT AND SO IT AND PART OF
WHAT I WAS STRUGGLING WITH IS
HOW WOULD YOU KNOW THAT
SOMEONE'S GROWING.
.
MARIJUANA. OTHER THAN PICKING
THROUGH THE WINDOWS.
ATE IT IT BE THERE'S USUALLY IF
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE GETS
INFORMATION JUST USUALLY A TIP.
OR OR ITS SOMETHING THAT SOMEONE
HAS TOLD THEM OR THEY THERE IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY'RE. THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO BE IN THE SEA IT
BUT.
I WAS JUST STRUGGLING WITH HOW
HOW SO SO ONE IS I DO BELIEVE
THE RENTER SHOULD PAY THE FINE.
AYE AYE I BELIEVE THERE NEEDS
TO BE. A DIVERT DIFFERENTIATION
BETWEEN THE PLANTS THE NUMBER OF
PLANTS THAT ARE ALLOWED TO BE
GROWN.
UNDER PERSONALLY USE BY LAW AND
I DON'T REMEMBER WHAT THAT
NUMBER IS ANYMORE SIX SIX.
AND.
AND THAT IS EXCLUDED FROM THAT
FROM FROM THIS.
KIND OF OF OF CHANGE I GUESS IS
IS THE BEST WAY TO PUT IT. MY
THOSE ARE THE TWO WELL I THINK
THE EMPHASIS.
I WILL WORK WITH ALL THE FOLKS
TO MAKE SURE HIS FOCUS ON
ILLEGAL GROWS.
SO THAT EXCLUDES A LOT OF.
YOU KNOW THE ALLOWABLE.
CULTIVATION.
.
SO I GUESS I'D SAY I WILL
CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS I THINK I
UNDERSTAND TO BE A LANDLORD
DIDN'T WANT TO BE.
COLLATERAL INVOLVED IN THIS ONE
IT'S THE MAN.
YOU GOTTA MALEFACTORS OF SOME
SORT.
WE DON'T INTEND TO ADDRESS
LEGAL CULTIVATION.
AND A. ILLEGAL GROWS COME TO
LIGHT IN VARIOUS WAYS UNUSUAL
POWER BILLS RIGHT HA THAT THE
ILLEGAL GROWS I DON'T HAVE A
PROCESS SO LOWER FOCUSING ON
HERE ACTUALLY IS ON THESE
ILLEGAL GROWS WHICH COME TO
LIGHT HOWEVER THEY COME TO LIFE
RIGHT. THEY COME TO LIGHT TODAY.
AND JUST ALLOW THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY
WHEN YOU HAVE IN THE LEGAL GROVE
CANNABIS.
AND.
SO I GUESS I WILL. BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE APARTMENTS FOR SHE
IS REALTORS AND OTHERS POSSESS
PROPERTY FOLKS.
AND OF JUST LOOK AT BILL
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS.
THEIR CONCERNS
I APPRECIATE THAT I DEAFENED
WILL DO THAT.
SO MEMBERS YEAH I TO AS WELL
APPRECIATE WHAT.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AS I
JUST EXPRESSING THE CONCERNS AS
WELL. AS MAKING SURE THERE'S A
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN PROPERTY
OWNERS VERSUS THE LANDLORD WHO'S
ACTUALLY THE ONE VIOLATING THE
LAW. AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
THE PROPERTY OWNER HAS AWAY. MY
JUST A MINUTE.
RIGHT BUT NOT THAT SERVE THE
LANDLORD VIOLATED THE LAW THE
TENET IS TO ONE CORRECT THE
TENANT VIOLATING THE LAW AND
THEN THE THE LANDLORD AT.
WOULD HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAL AND MAKE SURE AND GET YOU
RT'S STATE IF YOU CAN WORK WITH
OPPOSITION IS OPPOSITION OKAY
WITH.
THE AUTHORS COMMITMENT. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY PERFECT THEM WERE
HAPPY TOGETHER YEAH BUT NOT.
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LACKEY.
YES MA'AM THANK YOU AND.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND I
I KNOW HIM WELL ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT HE WILL WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. BECAUSE I KNOW THAT.
THEIR CONCERNS HE SHARES.
AND SO WE SHOULD KNOW THAT.
.
RIGHT NOW WE GOT THE THE
REVENUE.
REPORT JUST RECENTLY CAME MEN.
AND.
.
THE INCOME THAT WAS PROJECTED.
VERSUS WHAT WE ACTUALLY RECEIVED
FROM CANNABIS WAS ABOUT A THEFT.
AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
QUIT SMOKING MARIJUANA.
IT'S BIG OR USING IN ANY FASHION
BY THE WAY.
IT'S BECAUSE ILLICIT MARKET AS
JUST.
KICK IN THE TAIL OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO PLAY BY THE
RULES.
SO WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO FORTIFY THOSE WHO ARE.
PLAYING BY THE RULES AND BE VERY
VERY SHE.
STRINGENT AGAINST THOSE WHO ARE
NOT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION OSUNA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON LIFE'S
HARD THANK YOU KNOW I THINK A
LOT OF WHAT I WAS GOING TO ASK
AS WE SAID BECAUSE I REALLY
STRUGGLED WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE.
I SEE YOU KNOW THIS.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OF SAYING I AM THE SAME
WITH THE FOLKS IN OPPOSITION ARE
SAYING. AND YOU KNOW WHEN I LOOK
AT IT AND IT'S TIED TO. A NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT IT WOULD HAVE TO
BE TIED TO SOMETHING IN THE
BUILDING IN THE PLUMBING
ELECTRICAL OR OTHER THAN THAT
COULD. INCREASE THE FEES THAT
HER ALSO GOING TO BE FIND AND
I'M THINKING. WELL IF THE
LANDLORD KNOWS OF ONE POINT OR
THE LAND LOW LORD KNOWS AT A
LATER TIME IT'S STILL THE SAME
OUTCOME BECAUSE THE TENANTS
MOVE.
SO YEARS OLD WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS.
YOU'RE FINDING THE PROPERTY
OWNER AND.
FIVE I KIND OF THE STRUGGLING
WITH THAT PART OF IT BECAUSE AND
THE QUESTION I HAD WAS.
AS AS OF APARTMENT DEPARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WHEN WOULD LANDLORD
EVEN KNOW THERE WAS.
I MEAN WHO WOULD INFORM THEM LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR HEAD OF THE.
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT WE USUALLY
KNOW IF LAW ENFORCEMENT TELLS US
BUT THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT TENANTS HAVE A RIGHT
TO PRIVACY WE HAVE NO RIGHT TO
PROACTIVELY INSPECT. ANTENNAS
ALL THE TIME TELL US NO YOU
CAN'T. YOU KNOW THEY WANT THEIR
RIGHT TO PRIVACY NOT JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE ACTIVITY SO
WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
THAT WE WOULD ONLY KNOW. IF WE
HAD A CLAIM.
WERE SHERIFFS OR EVEN TENANTS
IT TURNS ROUND EACH OTHER ALL
THE TIME FOR THINGS THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ILLEGAL BUT YOU KNOW
THERE MATCH OTHER SO WE HAVE TO
BE. SENSITIVE THERE TOO.
SO USUALLY I WE DO NOW IS WHEN.
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS TOLD.
BECAUSE IT HAS ALSO PAY THEIR
OWN UTILITY BILLS SO WE DON'T
SEE I CAN UTILITIES BECAUSE WE
DON'T SEE THAT HE HAD A MASTER
METER SITUATION MAY BE SOME WHO
WOULD COME TO LIGHT BUT I DON'T
THINK YOU ASSUME THAT THAT'S.
WOULD BE TYPICAL RIGHT AYE
OFFICE ALMOST LIKE. OWNERS KIND
OF CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF YOU
KNOW COULD BE A SMELL COULD BE
UNUSUAL ACTIVITY THAT DOESN'T
REALLY FIT A RESIDENTIAL. UNIT.
GOOD THE A WHAT YOU SEE BEING
HOLDEN.
OR HEAR THUMPING IN THE DEAD OF
NIGHT.
BUT I'M AFRAID.
SO.
A RESERVE MY VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION RENEA
SECONDS.
SO.
GO SECOND BY A SOME MEMBER
LACKEY.
I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
BUT I US OBVIOUS THAT WE NEED TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION I THINK
YOU GUYS WILL COME TO SOMETHING.
AND AS.
SOME MEMBER LACKEY SAYS WE KNOW
THE U. YOU'LL WORK HARD WITH
THIS ONE.
BUT IS AN ISSUE.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S SOMETHING ARE
THE FINGER POINTING RIGHT NOW
WHO'S WHO'S IN CHARGE OF THIS
AND I'VE SEEN EVEN IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
SOMEONE LEFT THE POLICE OFFICERS
KNOW AND THAT NIGHT IT WAS
MOVING OUT AND LIKE WHERE DID
ALL THE EVIDENCE GO AND SO
ANYWAY I WOULD JUST A. FEW SHEET
THESE THEIR WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH ELSE
ABOUT YOUR BILL A COMMAND CHAIR.
OKAY.
.
PROJECT AYE VOTE. SECRETARY
CULTURAL. EMOTION IS DO PASS.
ADWARE CURRY. I WEAR CURRY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO CAVIAR AYE
COOLEY AYE AYE COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON.
MASON I LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
IN THE.
MEASURES OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
WILL MOVE ON TO AND NUMBER SIX
THE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON WILL BE
A FILLING IN TO THEY FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE FOR
BILL TWO THREE TWO NINE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER FOR STEPPING
IN.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE.
.
I M. PRESENTING A. B. TWO THREE
TWO NINE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
AND.
I'D LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
TWO OF THE ANALYSIS ON BEHALF OF
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
AND AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE
ALLOWS PARITY FOR COMPENSATION.
FOR BOARD MEMBERS OF VARIOUS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS MOST SPECIAL
DISTRICTS TO MEET UP TO SIX
TIMES A MONTH IF NEEDED. BUT
CURRENT LAW ALSO ALLOWS MOST
SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO ADOPT AN
ORDINANCE
TO RAISE THE COMPENSATION BY A
MAXIMUM OF FIVE PERCENT A YEAR.
HOWEVER SOME SPECIAL DISTRICTS
HAVE A LOWER CAP.
ON MEETINGS OR DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE THEIR
COMPENSATION PUTTING THEM AT A
DISADVANTAGE.
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE WILL
SOLVE THIS INEQUITY BY BRINGING
A HANDFUL OF TYPES OF SPECIAL
DISTRICTS UP TO PAR BY ALLOWING
THEM TO MEET UP TO SIX TIMES A
MONTH. AND ALLOWING THEM THE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE THEIR
COMPENSATION.
AND OF THESE OR SIMPLY
ALLOWANCES AND THAT LEAVE THE
DECISIONS LOCAL BOARDS TO KNOW
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY.
AND WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
DILLON GIBBONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
FEEL FREE TO START HER.
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
DELEGATE IS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AS IS MENTIONED MANY OF OUR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS RECEIVE A
MODEST COMPENSATION FOR DOING
THE BUSINESS OF THEIR DISTRICTS.
ATTENDING MEETINGS.
VARIOUS HEARINGS.
HOWEVER THAT COMPENSATION
VARIES WIDELY FROM DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT AND AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE.
BRING SOME UNIFORMITY TO NUMBER
OF THOSE DISTRICTS.
AT WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING THE
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY FOR DISTRICTS
TO MAKE A DECISION ON WHETHER OR
NOT THEY INCREASE THAT
COMPENSATION ANNUALLY.
THE NUMBER OF MEETINGS THAT
THEY WILL ACTUALLY HOLD.
AND MAKE THAT DETERMINATION OF
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S NECESSARY OR
JUSTIFIED.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD ASK IN URGE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU OTHER OTHERS AT A WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
A SUMMER RECOVERY OF THE SIX
REALLY HOW YOU KNOW. YEAH YOU
KNOW WHAT I AM I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY BUT FRANKLY.
HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING THAT
A FIRE DISTRICT THEN AIRPORT
DISTRICT OR UP PUBLIC CEMETERY
DISTRICT NEEDS TO MEET SIX TYPE
THEM.
FRANKLY.
I SERVED ON THE CITY COUNCIL WE
MET ONCE A WEEK AND. THEY WERE
LONG MEETINGS BUT YOU GOT IT
DONE I I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH INCREASE IT INCREASING THE
FEES I JUST MUCH RATHER JUST SAY
INCREASE THE FEES RATHER THAN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF MEETINGS.
UP AND THEN HAVE ONE THING ON
YOUR AGENDA EVERY MEETING SO
THAT YOU CAN GET EXTRA MONEY AND
THAT'S MY TWO CENTS WORTH SO.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
BUT.
BUT SIX MEETINGS JUST SEEMED.
BENT BENT INCLUDING THE
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS WE WE TOOK
A LOOK AT SOME OF THESE HAVE
HOPE THAT HER DISTRICT IF THEY
MET ONCE A MONTH THAT WAS
AMERICA. SO ANYWAY JUST DOWN I'M
IT'S NOT YOUR BILL AND I DON'T
EXPECT YOU TO ANSWER IT BUT I DO
I JUST FEEL COMPELLED TO SAY.
THE RATHER THAN MAKING IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
I'D RATHER JUST INCREASE THE
THAT COMPENSATION THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT A HUNDRED BUCKS A
MEETING YOU'RE NOT GETTING RICH.
SOME.
IF CHAIR FIVE TO FIVE A RESPONSE
IF.
AND.
I WOULD I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT A PERCENT.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE THIS
DOES MAINTAIN THAT LOCAL CONTROL
FOR THEM TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION HOW MANY MEETINGS
ARE NECESSARY. I THINK THERE ARE
CERTAIN TIMES WERE FIRE
DISTRICTS WILL BE NEEDING TO
MEET YOU KNOW SIX SEVEN TIMES IN
A MONTH I THINK THAT THAT. THAT
THE CHAIR WOULD BE VERY AWARE OF
OF WHY THAT MIGHT MAY BE
NECESSARY TO THESE THINGS COME
UP.
HOPEFULLY IT IT IT'S RARE AYE.
AYE ADDITIONALLY AYE I WOULD
IMAGINE THE CEMETERY DISTRICT
WOULD NEED TO MEET SIX TIMES A
MONTH.
HOWEVER IF THE UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES DEPENDING ON WHAT.
THE SITUATION IS AT THAT LEVEL
THEY MAY NEED TO.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
IF THE CAR IS FILLED WITH
EMOTION.
AND SECOND.
OKAY ANY FURTHER.
MANY QUESTIONS OF HISSING NONE
REJECT CLOSED MISSPOKE UP ON
BEHALF OF MISTER OBERNOLTE I
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY WITH THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SECRETARY CULTURAL. THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED ACT WHERE
CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO KABIRA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE MULLIN.
WHO MULLIN AYE?
VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
THIS IS.
OFFICIALS AT NINE ZERO. OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL AND
THOSE OF YOU WILL GO THROUGH.
ALL THE BILLS RIGHT NOW.
ALL ALL THE ATOMS.
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM ONE A. B.
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR ITEM TEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
ITEM TWELVE AB TO THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR. ITEM THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN SENATE
BILLS FOURTEEN NINETY SIX
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND
FOURTEEN. NINETY NINE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
LACKEY AYE AYE LACKEY AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
ITEM TO AB NINETEEN HUNDRED
PEROT. MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE GIPSON LACKEY I'VE
LACKEY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO GLORIA BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT PEROT.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB THIRTY ONE
NINETY FOUR.
WALDRON.
WALDRON NO MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
FIFTH THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR ATTENDANCE TODAY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
THE DAY WITHOUT OBJECTION. I
WILL GROWTH WILL ADJOURN THE
MEETING THANK YOU VERY MUCH